on this friday night shrinking social
circles to curb
covet 19. the new urgency as quebec's
cases rise and manitoba lays down
new rules we need to reduce our
community transmission
the risks of covid19 on connecting
flights in canada
why don't people flying into this
country have to quarantine at the first
point of entry
a daughter's heartbreak he got killed in
a mosque
and the mounting pressure to eliminate
hate groups in canada plus the unhappy
and the undecided i don't like either
candidate a campaign conundrum our mike
armstrong
is in pennsylvania tonight
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is mid-october it's getting colder
it's getting dark
earlier we've been enduring this
pandemic for eight months now and
restrictions on the lives of millions of
canadians
are getting tighter there's only one way
to change that it's by reducing who we
come into contact with
and that is the message in quebec today
where more than one thousand new cases
of covid19 were reported again
if we decrease by one contact per person
one contact that is important
if we go from five to four as it's very
clear in the study
that could make a huge difference over
the next four weeks
that is the message in ontario too where
more than 700 new cases of coven 19 were
reported today
another region york has now been moved
into stage two of ontario's restrictions
that means no indoor dining or drinking
and gyms and movie theaters must close
the restrictions begin monday and last
for 28 days
we can't allow this virus to get into
our long-term care homes
we need to protect our schools and our
communities
we need to keep performing vital
surgeries
in our hospitals we need to stop the
spread before things get worse
here are the numbers from across canada
today ontario and quebec continue
to have the highest number of new covid
19 cases manitoba reported 75 today
saskatchewan 40. alberta reported 332
and b.c 155 there are also now three
presumptive positive
cases in the northwest territories there
is some relief in manitoba that today's
case count didn't set another record but
the spread of covet 19 in that province
especially in winnipeg
has been alarming manitoba had the most
active cases per capita of any province
this week and
today new mandatory restrictions were
announced
including limiting gatherings to just
five people
as brittany greenslade explains the
message is clear reduce the number of
people
you come into contact with it was just a
quick catch up with a friend over ice
cream
but for 22 year old winnipegger elena
expanding her bubble
ended with covid 19. you have no idea
where
who your family's circle is and you have
no idea
who your friend's circle is and it's
causing rising case numbers
expanded groups large gatherings and bar
hopping have put winnipeg's test
positivity rate
over 6 percent manitoba now the covid 19
hot spot of the country hitting the
highest number of active cases per
capita in canada
and winnipeg is ground zero these
numbers show
we have lost their way starting monday
new sweeping restrictions are coming to
the capitol
they include the closure of all bars
nightclubs and casinos
restaurants limited to 50 percent
capacity with liquor sales ending at 10
p.m and gatherings restricted to five
people
we need to reduce our community
transmission of this virus
we need to reduce the number of
hospitalizations and deaths
and to do that we need to keep our
contacts down
dr brent russon says the restrictions
will be implemented for at least
two weeks two weeks everyone really
step up here we start seeing a real
change in these numbers we can
start looking at these restrictions and
loosening them as appropriate
if not then we have to look at further
restrictions brittany greenslade global
news
winnipeg though the border with the u.s
is closed to non-essential travel that
does not mean
no one is flying into canada from other
countries in fact tens of thousands of
people are doing it every month
they must quarantine for 14 days and
submit a plan on where they intend to do
that but
if they say they have no symptoms they
are free to board connecting flights to
their final destination in canada
potentially spreading covid19 as they go
they don't need to quarantine at the
first point of entry and as abigail
beeman explains
a lot of people think that needs to
change
for months flying has looked different
everyone's in protective gear you know
and they sanitize so it feels pretty
safe
and the government has maintained the
risk is low but now
studies in the upcoming journal from the
centers for disease control refute that
our results strongly suggest in-flight
transmission says one
another provides evidence of
asymptomatic transmission of kovid 19
on an airplane and a third concludes the
risk for onboard transmission of sars
cole v2
during long flights is real and can
provide conditions for super spreader
events
there's no question that when you put
lots of people in a tight air space
you've got
risk and are airplanes safe enough given
that people are wearing masks and given
that there's ventilation and filtering
the answer is no the public health
agency of canada tells global news it's
not aware of any confirmed cases
of in-flight passenger to passenger
transmission of covid19
in this country but here's what many
canadians may not realize
when someone flies here from a foreign
country and doesn't show
symptoms they don't need to quarantine
until they reach their final destination
that means thousands board connecting
flights to destinations
right across the country in april may
and june combined about 200 thousand
passengers arrived in canada from
another country
and 34 thousand of them went on to a
connecting flight domestically
the numbers jumped in july 154
000 international arrivals with 33 000
passengers boarding a connecting flight
other countries new zealand and
australia have made point of entry
quarantine mandatory
by isolating for two weeks insecure
accommodation
epidemiologist colin furness thinks
canada should too
i think transport canada has not been
stepping up to its obligations i think
health canada
has not tried to bridge the gap the
transport minister's office declined
multiple interview requests for this
story
global news spoke with a flight
attendant who wouldn't go on camera
concerned about
job retribution the flight attendant
told us they were exposed to covet 19
on the job more than once from infected
travelers and had to stay
off the job with pay self-monitoring or
self-isolating each time
this flight attendant has never tested
positive but believes point-of-entry
quarantine would help lower exposures
concerned people may conceal symptoms to
get home
and contaminate airport staff crew and
passengers
in the process as someone in our flight
was sitting next to that person and then
they happened to take off the mask and
drink water then
we all exposed i mean it doesn't feel
good but there's not much i can do about
it
i don't think that they should
kathy gillis flew to toronto for cancer
treatment and believes in point of entry
quarantine
concerned about those who may be sitting
near her on her trip home to northern
ontario
i wouldn't come if i didn't have to
the government does have a website
tracking potential exposures on flights
within the past
14 days on friday there were 34
international flights on the list and 48
domestic
abigail beeman global news ottawa
now to the simmering dispute over the
indigenous lobster fishery in nova
scotia
prime minister justin trudeau called for
calm today the indigenous services
minister has said he fears people
may die if tensions keep escalating but
there is no solution on the horizon and
as ross lord reports there remains a
sinister
undercurrent to the dispute
once again first nations lobster fishers
have been stymied
their buoys and trap lines sabotaged
trap lines are being cut
as we speak and the commercial fishermen
are preventing our people from
exercising their right to a moderate
livelihood
chief mike sack of sebagon eggety says
the department of fisheries and oceans
is not protecting
indigenous fishing boats a problem he
outlined in a letter to the prime
minister
here's the reply we're calling for an
end
to the violence and the harassment
that's happening
we need to make sure that our security
officials our police
are there to make sure everyone is
protected as well
i understand the concerns
and the the conflict going on right now
but we need to find a solution the chief
says most sebago negativity harvesters
came in off the water friday to avoid
trouble
a move some are reluctant to make yeah
it's not right that we have to avoid
them
you know they're the ones doing the
criminal acts they torched my van just
the other day
emotions are spilling over on both sides
with
canada pegging us as racist
terrorists
it's the hardest on us cindy como fishes
with her husband joelle
he resigned from the maritime
fisherman's union executive
on top of current tensions he blames
harassment
and threats against his family from
non-indigenous people
who he says profit from a separate black
market fishery
the fishery he says is much larger than
the one sanctioned
by sebagon agony we've been followed
around we've had people in our driveway
verbal verbal attacks indigenous fishers
say they're facing other forms of
resistance unable to buy bait locally
for their lobster traps
or have work done on their boats they're
telling them
you know if you if you help the natives
we're not supporting you we're
boycotting you
with no change in position on either
side and ongoing threats and violence
the search for a common understanding
remains elusive
ross lord global news sonia veale nova
scotia
the news that a decades-old murder case
has finally been solved in ontario has
made headlines and the police have been
congratulated for finally finding the
man who they say killed
nine-year-old christine jessup but it
raises all kinds of questions
too why did it take 36 years why was a
neighbor
of the jessups wrongly accused and
convicted and why did police overlook
the real killer
jessop's family has spent decades living
with grief and uncertainty
tonight global's karen lieberman speaks
with the murdered girl's mother
and brother 36 years have passed since
janet jessup's daughter
kenny's little sister went missing
relieved
that we finally have the answer we've
waited for
three months after christine jessup
disappeared from the family home
in queensville ontario her body was
found
it was new year's eve 1984. the
nine-year-old had been
sexually assaulted and stabbed police
searched for the killer like anything in
this case it couldn't be a simple answer
their neighbor gee paul moren was
arrested and wrongfully convicted
eventually acquitted based on dna
evidence
decades passed without a development and
the case went cold
always there's hope but did you have any
expectation
that this day would come you dreamed it
might happen
you know and what would you do then just
days after they visited christine's
grave site
to mark yet another anniversary of her
death if
he were alive today the toronto police
service would arrest calvin hoover
for the murder of christine jessup i
remembered his face when they showed the
mug shot
you always suspected it was someone who
knew christine
someone who knew your family and they'd
come up and play
because we had the space or we go down
for a barbecue at their house
you know the men would go one way the
women would go the other and the kids
were
sitting in the backyard would pop calvin
hoover's wife had worked with christine
jessup's father
angry about who it is frustrated upset
betrayal betrayal that's a huge one too
that's a good word yeah hoover died by
suicide in 2015
but the jessips find solace in knowing
he was christine's killer
identified via genetic genealogy a
forensic technique that combines dna
analysis
with genealogical research what's in
your mind when you think about christine
i mean she had a chance to live and she
should have had that chance
while there is no happy ending here this
conclusion
janet and kenny jessup say allows them
to reflect on christine
as the happy-go-lucky child she was now
we can really look back
and fo just focus on the good memories
it's done it's finally over
karen lieberman global news toronto
the daughter of a man killed outside a
toronto mosque last month is speaking
out for the first time bibi zephiz
is not only mourning her murdered father
she is sounding the alarm
as far nasser reports threats against
mosques are on the rise in this country
he brought joy to
my life from the day i born until
now shabana bibi zafiz shows us a
childhood photo her father carried in
his wallet for decades
but that pictures is like i was his
light but
it leaves me now how
do i live on september 12th muhammad
aslim zafiz a toronto mosque caretaker
had just finished prayers and went
outside his daughter
shared security video from the building
you can see a man walking by
he watches the feasts before killing him
and see my dad sit in a chair
and someone comes from the back and go
like this and stab
him i've
i don't know i felt like in my mind he's
not gone
thirty-four-year-old william von
neutegum has been charged with
first-degree murder
it was a tragedy it was a hate crime
bernie farber chair of the canadian
anti-hate group says
von nudigem followed a satanic neo-nazi
hate group
founded in the united kingdom farber and
others have sent an open letter to the
prime minister calling for a national
action plan to dismantle white supremacy
and neo-nazi groups in this country
no brother should be sitting in the
parking lot right here and just you've
all seen the video no one should be in
the parking lot and be worried about his
life
today prime minister justin trudeau said
his government is extremely concerned
with the rise of intolerance
but wouldn't commit to a national plan
according to the national council of
canadian muslims
every major mosque in downtown toronto
has received threats in the past six
months
the council says threats escalated after
ramadan when the call to prayer was
played out loud from mosques as
worshipers were not allowed inside
he didn't got killed out on the street
he got killed
in a mosque this blurry selfie is the
last one
shabana bibi zafiz has with her father
but she cherishes it
while worrying about the next muslim
family that could be torn apart
by hate farah nasser global news toronto
the dilemma for undecided voters coming
up we head to pennsylvania where
disgruntled voters are trying to pick a
candidate
in less than three weeks the u.s
presidential election will take place
though there may not be a clear result
because of the millions of mail-in
ballots that won't get counted right
away
with the country so polarized it may
feel like everyone's made up their
mind how to vote already but that's not
what our mike armstrong found in lucerne
county pennsylvania
it's a swing county the majority voted
for obama twice and then for trump in
2016.
and now mike found voters less than
enthusiastic
about either candidate there are voters
here
who have definitely picked aside in fact
these neighbors are so entrenched
they're not actually speaking to each
other but right next door
is marion foose undecided she's
unimpressed with
either candidate no not really
no that's not a fun situation to be in
no
when the voters of this county go to the
polls you expect to vote
some will be casting a ballot while
holding their nose
well neither option seems like it's
really
that great i don't like either
candidates there's pros and cons to both
of them
i don't think anybody's satisfied with
choosing one or the other party it's
kind of
picking the less of both evils it's a
strange way to think about an election
it's been called
winning the haters getting the people
who dislike both candidates
to vote for your side it was a big
factor in donald trump's 2016 victory
according to exit polls nationally 18
percent of voters had an
unfavorable view of both candidates
trump trounced hillary clinton with that
group 47 percent
to just 30. in pennsylvania trump won
the so-called haters
by 25 percent on his way to eking out a
victory in the state by barely
one percent you are the american people
and you will decide our future
not trump
now there's a big difference this time
around joe biden
isn't as polarizing a figure as hillary
clinton
i think if joe biden was able to run
four years ago he would have beaten
donald trump
the so-called haters appear to have
swung around according to one poll of
the voters who will be holding their
noses
bidens leading 60 percent to just 10
a number like that would have a massive
impact
on election day mike armstrong global
news wilkes-barre pennsylvania
ahead big trouble for the king of
thailand
you're watching global national
tens of thousands of people in bangkok
thailand defied a ban
on gatherings to demand reform of the
monarchy police used water cannon to
disperse them
protesters started taking to the streets
in july they want the wealthy and
powerful thai king to be
accountable to the people and want the
prime minister to resign
police in france are calling a horrific
attack on a teacher an act of terrorism
investigators say a man with a knife
killed a middle school history teacher
decapitating him in front of a school in
a paris suburb
the attacker was shot and killed by the
police the teacher had recently shown
his class cartoons of the prophet
muhammad to open a discussion about
freedom of speech and blasphemy police
say he'd received threats
after that next could your blood type
increase your risk of getting covid19
the learning curve about covid19 has
been steep for all of us and the virus
is still
outsmarting scientists and doctors in
the meantime all we can do is keep
protecting ourselves
tonight jeff semple takes more of your
questions to the experts
trick-or-treating in a pandemic might
seem spooky
but this montreal mom has engineered a
creative solution
a candy chute allowing safe distanced
delivery really excited
but alas not every home comes equipped
with a candy slide
which raises the question should covet
19 cancel
trick or treat people should as much as
possible
follow local public health guidance and
the local advice
varies ottawa for example a provincial
hot spot is asking residents to stay
home
but most jurisdictions say ghosts and
ghouls can proceed
with caution maintaining distancing
perhaps incorporating masks as part of
your
costume and definitely safe distribution
of of treats definitely not having
anyone coming into homes
my name is tina and i'm in calgary
and i would like to know more about the
connection
between different blood types and the
severity of infection
two new studies including one from
vancouver suggest that people with blood
type
o may be less vulnerable to covet 19 and
less likely to become
severely sick so what we have here is a
statistical signal
that maybe requires some further
investigation but it's way too early to
conclude
that it's due to something innate to
your biology
jeff semple global news toronto and that
is global national for this friday i'm
donna friesen tonight's your canada is a
remarkable discovery in horseshoe canyon
in alberta's badlands
if the school is complete this is what
it would look like that's nathan
hiroshkin who
spotted the bones of a hadrosaur while
out hiking with his dad
experts say his find will help fill a
gap in knowledge from a period 69
million years ago
not bad for a 12 year old who loves
dinosaurs and says
he wants to be a paleontologist one day
thanks for watching have a lovely
weekend
take care of yourselves bye
you